this may be a reality for you now a new
reality of having to stay at home a
whole lot more and we appreciate how
difficult that can be so we want to talk
about it and we'll do it with undress
Kappas who is a social psychologist and
neuroscientist also a lecturer in the
Department of Psychology at the
University of London Andres thank you
for joining us I feel like it's a
step-by-step process and maybe the first
step for people is just having to get
over the idea that this is just how it
is now there isn't a lot you can do
about it and you need to almost get over
that psychological hump before thinking
about anything anything else yes that's
a that's a great observation I think we
all crave kind of like a feeling of
control of our lives that we all have to
give that somewhat up but I think for
some people that might actually kind of
be expressed in a very well you know not
in a good way such that they are trying
to get the control back over their life
and I think the best way to do it is to
consume to vary more about the
coronavirus to consume a lot of news to
try to kind of make up for this feeling
of control by this illusion of control
by watching TV by watching the news by
checking Twitter or seeing what's going
on on Facebook kind of trying to get
this feeling back and that might feed
them into the very about what is going
to happen with my life so I think one of
the things we should realize is that
more information more watching TV more
news is not a solution if you catch
yourself being overly concerned with the
situation you might want to kind of
restrict your media consumption and stay
away a little bit from that yeah not a
bad time to put the phone down isn't it
tell me about the links also between
physical and mental health I think a lot
of people will be worrying about
physical health and thinking I need to
try to keep fit
but that presumably can tie in and help
with people's mental health yes I think
it's a great observation just in general
if you look at what makes people happy
physical activity what keeps us happy
what keeps us productive physical
activity is a very good point I think
even more important a social interaction
I think we've really underestimate if
you're socially isolated at home we
underestimate how important Monday
interactions in our lives how much they
keep us happy so just like normally we
think like oh I can do without the
conversation at the grocery shop or
talking to my colleague at the coffee
machine but these really contribute to
our well-being so it's important to kind
of keep in mind and allow yourself to
have mundane interactions with your
relatives and your phone is you might
sometimes feel well why should I call my
mother just to tell her that basically
nothing happens name I shouldn't call it
but you should give yourself the
permission to kind of have ordinary
boring conversations with others because
they really contributes you our feeling
of happiness and being connected to
others I think calling your mom is
always good advice um one thing which is
different in the situation we have now
is that it is open-ended isn't it often
if you know maybe you were ill or you've
had an accident you broke your leg you
know you're going to be at home for four
weeks or six weeks here none of us
actually know do you have any
recommendations for again getting over
that hump because I think that's where a
lot of desperation comes from thinking
oh my god how long is this gonna go on
yeah so in some ways like a Symetra
response right you're you're in a
situation that everyone tells you is
severe is important that restricts your
life but they can't really tell you much
they're very different sources of
information time two different things
I think the biggest advice I can give
here is just to kind of find something
in your life that you might focus on
instead so yesterday when I was out and
trying to do some shopping I saw a lot
of people rushing to the DIY stores to
the hardware stores to the gardening
centers and I think that's a very good
idea to kind of select okay get a sense
of control get a sense of achievement
back into your life by having a little
project but trying to improve your god
we're trying to improve your flag or
maybe just learning a new language that
gives you this feeling back the
different control that you can achieve
things and that might also get you away
from being preoccupied with the
uncertainty of the situation so instead
of kind of trying to focus on it say you
know what you're supposed to do there's
nothing else you can do okay let's leave
that let's focus on something else that
can give me some feeling of control and
joy and achievement and there's cappers
thank you for your time great advice and
I'm sure our audience appreciates it as
well thank you